i feel like
everywhere you hear about drone strikes
or you hear about these drone operations
and the massive civilian casualties
it's always synonymous with yemen
and drone strikes so synonymous um
mostly because we shouldn't even be over
there
and uh um yemen is a humanitarian crisis
going on right now like there is the
children are starving
entire places are being devastated
and um the excuse that was given to me
was that
their government requested us
to help them out um so
when i was in the third sos the end of
my enlistment
i was a part of an operation to track
down and
hunt anwar al-awlaki who was
an islamic imam a holy man
this guy when 9 11 happened was invited
to the white house by the bush
administration
and was even friends with the obama
administration
like went to the white house and was
like yeah we need to be over there there
are
you know radical islam is not islam
where is this guy originally from anwar
al-awlaki for people who don't know his
full story like
he's from yemen okay
but he was a united states citizen and
lived in colorado
um i think colorado springs actually if
i'm if we want to be specific
and his son abdullah rahman
lived here too right and so
when anwar al-awlaki he was invited he
you know being a celebrity in his
religion he was invited to go
to mosques all over the world and he
especially of course any compassionate
religious figure would go and help his
people regardless like
one of my favorite phrases is from the
bhagavad-gita
when lord krishna is talking to arjuna
and he's saying
he's like anyone can come to me whether
they be good or evil and i will give
them fair judgment
right and i think that my grandfather
was the same way like if
anyone came to him regardless of whether
they were the worst scum in the world
or the noblest of saints he would still
talk to them
as if they you know they're still human
and so
uh anwar went to the went to a mosque
and of course there were people that
were opposed
to what the u.s government was doing
over there coming and talked to them and
he was giving them advice we don't know
what advice he was i wasn't told what
advice
but we got video of him talking to
known members of i think hamas
and just that alone right there was
enough for people to be like okay
we should kill him but then he was like
he saw the devastation that was
happening
in him he saw what we were doing and
what was going on he was like the united
states is wrong
the united states is wrong in this and
you know what they decided to do
but kill him uh right before
anywhere sorry to interrupt but i feel
like anywhere
you are whether you're in the united
states africa
yemen if you see a
exorbitant amount of innocent people
being slaughtered
for no reason you're going to feel
extremely passionate about
or extreme you're going to feel
compassion
compassion and or resentment
for whoever is doing that whoever's
responsible for that
yeah and uh i remember that my
leadership was you know every brief that
we'd have they'd be like this guy
deserves to die he's a traitor of the
united states blah blah blah blah
but um no one really you know one of the
first
times i actually ever read the
constitution
was at the end of my enlistment you know
we're talk we swear an oath to this
thing yet we don't have to [ __ ]
understand it or know it no one teaches
us they just like do you swear to uphold
the constitution
right everybody talks about it yeah um
that's all we know yeah right um
uh and so i i remember coming in on
one day and one of the pilots i'm gonna
just i'm gonna name him
and i hope he forgives me but i respect
this guy a lot
his name was chris ayers he was a major
in the air force
and uh him and i him and i had a game
going on wherever he was a briefing
i would go in and i would change one of
his slides to say
something silly or stupid or i would
like copy
one of the slides like 10 times so that
when you
clicked the button it would go to the
same slide
so him and i him and i would play these
games to just entertain ourselves
and i remember coming in one day and he
looked like he was like this he was like
oh my god like he looked sick
and i go up and i was like hey sir
what's going on like
what's up and he was like we're now
going to be flying armed in yemen
when previously we weren't you know the
the
episode that i said that i flew the
longest mission that was a yemen mission
and it was we were flying unarmed with
no second pod
because we were just doing visual and
it was february of 2011 and he's just
like yeah we're flying armed now
and if we are given the order to kill
anwar al-awlaki president obama himself
will call up the gcs
ground control station and give the
order and i was like
awesome like we're gonna kill this guy
like it's probably gonna be me
right like i'm probably going to be the
dude that's going to do it is he
one uh there was three of us there were
three crews that that flew this mission
because it was so high profile
what did you guys know about anwar
al-awlaki at that time
uh nothing like we just knew that he was
a traitor i didn't look him up
i didn't know anything i was just doing
what i was told
right um i
i would didn't look watch the news or do
any of that type of stuff because
it just i knew from what they were
reporting
versus what we were doing i knew that
they were reporting back
right and um i was like
i was like all right we're finally going
to get this mission done uh
so what's the problem and he looks at me
and he's like church
don't you understand that our
constitution says that even a traitor
deserves a fair and free trial
in front of a jury of his peers we're
violating
we're violating it we're violating
everything that i swore to do
and i was kind of like whoa really
he's like yeah he's like this is this is
wrong
um and
i i remember um i said we have to build
a mission profile a mission folder
uh before every every launch and as i
was
usually the person that launched the
aircraft i was the one that was making
this folder so
i'm sitting at the computer and i'm
putting it together i'm putting the
dossier together
and i get this sense of i'm standing at
the printer
and i get the sense of vertigo like like
i'm
thinking to myself yeah i'm probably
gonna be the one to kill this guy
i want the like if obama taught like i
voted obama into office
right like i voted this guy i'm gonna
get an order from the president of the
united states
the guy who i voted into off like i just
had
it was like this euphoria
and then i remembered my first shot i
had forgotten about it i remember what
my mom said
and my mom said that you know as soon as
you want to do it
that means that you are no longer
capable of carrying the responsibility
of doing it right
and i don't know if you've heard of a
book series called the wheel of time
that's one of my favorite book series i
read it i've read it five times um
and it's a super long series but there's
one point one of the characters gets an
axe and he's this young boy and he's
like practicing
with it in the woods and he wants to he
wants to use it he wants to be this hero
and um he ends up
killing some other men and getting sick
like just horribly sick from it and his
mentor comes up and he says
he's like it's good that you feel this
way you know as soon as you want
to do it then you must throw that axe
away and rock the other way
and my mom said the same thing in
different words you know
like right after i had done it and so
like i had this echo like these this
this
um series that i had loved so much
and my mom's words and my grandfather's
teachings
just echoed within me and i had the
sense of vertigo that i was doing the
wrong thing and i was like i can't stay
in
i was i was thinking about maybe
re-enlisting i was thinking about like
had i re-enlisted they were going to
make me an m29
reaper operator i was going to get sent
down to white sands
[Music]
and then i was like i can't do this i
can't
be a part of this anymore um
and right before i got out uh it could
have been like right before i got out or
right
after no it was right after so i left
early i got
i got terminal leave 84 days of terminal
leave
and in april of that year they had their
first attempt to capture n while orlocki
and they failed um the aircr the
helicopter that was going after them had
a critical malfunction and crashed in
the middle of the desert and i think it
killed five marines
um so then they were like yeah we're
just going to kill him
and uh i had people keeping me updated
and then
later that year um anwar al-awlaki was
killed
and then his son abdullah rahman was
killed two weeks later
well i find out that abdullah rahman
what had happened was
as soon as anwar al-awlaki started
speaking out against the us government
they took his passport away and trapped
him in yemen couldn't come back
um which he intended to he intended to
come back and go to washington and make
a stink and being like this is wrong
you must stop this well instead he he
had power right he had
he was he was basically the um uh
islamic martin luther king right he
wasn't
trying to incite violence he was saying
that the united states was wrong
doing uh and then
he became more once they took his
passport away he became radicalized
and then his son who who ran away from
home
to find his father went to yemen uh was
killed in a drone strike because the
united states didn't want him to become
an icon like was anwar doing some crazy
[ __ ] like
praising the the guys who flew the
planes into the towers on 911 and and
was i don't i don't know about that i
just know that
once once his passport was taken from
him by the united states and he was
hunted down he became
and whatever he said uh
from that you know he was just super
[ __ ] pissed
right and his emotional state it's i'm
not excusing what he was saying i'm
saying that his emotional state
pushed him to to to into a he saw the
suffering and he took it on his as his
own and he
he did what he was believed was right
even if it was wrong
and one of the things that people don't
know about the trump administration
is that anwar's daughter was also in
yemen
at the beginning of trump's
administration and he ordered them to
kill her
because they didn't want her to become
an icon healer
so trump gave the order to kill an
eight-year-old girl
and that went through yeah it went
through
the the yemeni crisis is is wrong
on all fronts and i don't know what
they're searching for
over there i don't know there's there i
don't know what resources
or the destabilization or whatever
but if we if we even go back to sun
shoes the art of war
the way that you win a war is not
through violence the way that you win a
war
is by getting the people on your side
and the way that you get the people on
your side is not by inciting violence
but by giving them the resources that
they need to live a normal life
you know not everyone wants to be an
entrepreneur not everyone wants to be
rich ceo not everyone wants a golden
[ __ ] toilet seat
people just want to live their lives
free and happy
and what we're doing over in the middle
east is causing
the opposite of that